we promised you good news and we're
delivering it we told you some months
ago but 4 000 beagles that were slated
to be tortured for no real reason
at a research facility in virginia
tony fauci had purchased dogs from that
facility well a group called the white
coat waste project first uncovered the
abuse of the beagles and found purchase
records that show the abuse of several
dogs to be quote used in septic shock
experiments at nih the dogs were denied
food and eaten allied by bugs etcetera
sorry we're not going to go into details
because it's too depressing now a major
breeding facility for those research
facilities has been shut down and the
first batch of beagles has been set free
daphnakinovic is the senior vice
president peta and joins us tonight with
an update on this daphna thank you so
much for coming on so these beagles are
not going to be tortured
what's
congratulations we're celebrating what
happens to them now
thank you we are celebrating tucker
thanks for having me back on
next over the next 60 days or so they're
going to be transferred to the humane
society of the united states and from
there going to various shelters in
virginia and beyond the first group was
released yesterday to the tune of
approximately 400 and these are
thousands and thousands of dogs that
were bred for research the facility has
been there since 1961
and we are just thrilled that not a
single one of these four thousand
beagles will ever be tortured and killed
in a lab they will all have the
opportunity to find a loving home to
feel the grass under their paws the sun
on their back play with a toy and have a
name things that they have not had the
chance to experience thus far
ah
what was so upsetting about this story
was nobody could say with a straight
face well these dogs are being killed so
kids won't die of cancer there was no
there seemed to be no
justifiable reason to torture these dogs
to death or am i missing something
you are absolutely not missing something
and this is the tip of the iceberg we
are thrilled for these 4 000 dogs but
this facility was the second largest
provider of dogs for experiments in this
country there is a larger facility in
new york that has believe it or not 21
000 beagles these animals are bred and
sold for absolutely pointless painful
experiments and our federal government
has bought dogs from this facility since
september of 2020 the nih has had
contracts for live dogs at least three
contracts it is time for the nih to wake
up realize it's the 21st century and
move on to modern non-animal methods
yeah i mean there's just so much money
sloshing around the system
that to keep it flowing you know they
invent
experiments that benefit nobody um so
you can
you're saying just to be totally clear
on our way out in the next how long
until these dogs can be adopted by
people watching
the the plan for transfer will take
place over the next 60 days and we urge
people to just keep an eye and we are
just so thrilled that peta's undercover
investigation prompted this domino
effect that resulted not only in 74
violations and the department of justice
getting involved but the liberation of
these 4 000 dogs and we hope all the
cages get emptied next from all the
laboratories and all the breeding
facilities
this show is proudly for dogs so we're
celebrating thanks for coming on tonight
good to see you
thank you tucker so much for having me
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight